caleb is with us in fort walton beach hi
Caleb how are you I'm great mr. Andy how
are you doing better than I deserve
what's up so I've got a question for you
I've got about 44,000 and total debt I'm
in the military so I just got a some
back pay from @ey I did and so I've got
$4,500 on top of my emergency fund
sitting in my savings account and I'm
trying to side whether I should go ahead
and use that to pay off my car which is
about forty nine hundred dollars left or
if I should continue to save up a couple
a couple extra bucks from that to
purchase an engagement ring for my
soon-to-be fiance good for you
congratulations on your plans so what is
your income right around fifty seven
thousand okay and what is the forty four
thousand dollars in debt is the call
23,000 is student loans and sixteen
thousand dollars of it is a career
starter loan that I was falsely talked
into when I commissioned oh god I hate
those things all right and obviously the
military did not cover the education for
some reason or another why during the
when sequestrated
sequestration was going on so I was
ineligible for a scholarship at the time
okay all right and how long have you
been working on your debt paying it off
I've been in the military for three
years now
how long have you been working to pay
your debt off about a year and a half
now I paid off about fifteen thousand
and the year and a half I've been on
your plan good good for you okay what
are you thinking of spending on the ring
Oh somewhere around six maybe up to
$7,000 yes sir okay all right I think
you should buy the ring but I think you
too much budgeted okay I would buy the
ring with the four or five 4,500 you
shouldn't spend more than a month of
take-home pay on an engagement ring
so $4,000 rings gonna be just fine I got
married 33 years ago on an $1,100 ring
and it's worked out okay so size of ring
there's no correlation between size of
diamond and success of marriage as a
matter of fact there might be an inverse
correlation but um but uh we don't know
that this but I just made that up but
yeah I know I think that's just too much
I would spend this cash maximum on the
ring and then I get back to getting my
might get out of that plan hey thanks
for your service to the country sir this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here I hope you're enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my very own YouTube channel
yes that's right it's kind of better
than the Dave Ramsey channel don't tell
them I said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you